on this monday night promise and
potential progress
in the pursuit of a covet 19 vaccine
it's not the final news but it's great
news the early results
raising some hope of a shot at immunity
mounting resistance to more restrictions
we have to have a happy balance
ontario's dilemma over how to crush the
curve
as airlines struggle to fill flights
why one carrier is banking on a new
route between toronto
and a small bc city and the supporters
who hope president trump
triumphs trump chain baby trump train
the fans who are adamant
he is going to make america great again
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after eight months of covid 19 and a
second wave rising as winter approaches
it is easy to get discouraged and while
there's no end in sight to the pandemic
there is a glimmer of good news about
something that could get us on a path
out of the gloom
drug maker astrazeneca says the covid19
vaccine being developed at the
university of oxford
which is in the late stages of clinical
trials has had positive results in older
people
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine is one of
11 that has reached phase 3 clinical
trials in a field of
50 potential vaccines being worked on in
32 countries
never before have so many scientists
around the world been focused on this
single thing
a breakthrough is not guaranteed but in
our top story tonight eric sorenson
explains why the oxford vaccine appears
to be
the front runner it is a potentially
massive breakthrough
the vaccine being developed by
astrazeneca and oxford university
produces a robust
immune response similar in both older
and younger adults
the elderly have a weaker immune system
and are much more likely to get severely
ill from covet 19.
in canada close to 90 percent of deaths
have happened to people over the age of
70.
a vaccine that can protect the most
vulnerable would be a game changer
it's not the final news but it's great
news older people as we all know
are far more vulnerable to covet 19 and
those are the ones that need
the protection so they are showing a
robust immune response
and and even a little bit of weaker
lesser
side effects the astrazeneca vaccine
triggers a twin response one that
protects and one that attacks
it makes protective antibodies that bind
to the virus and neutralize it so it
cannot infect a healthy cell
where the virus does infect a cell t
cells can be activated to identify the
infected cell
kill that cell and with it the virus t
cells
are what help our antibodies kind of
become more efficient
they don't act individually they act in
concert together the astrazeneca trials
were halted temporarily after one
volunteer became sick
but restarted when the illness was not
deemed to have come from the vaccine
canada has committed more than 1 billion
dollars for 170 million doses from
several companies
including moderna and pfizer and that
includes 20 million doses from
astrazeneca
canada began a review of the astrazeneca
vaccine earlier this month
it's better to have a number of options
on the table rather than saying we're
stuck with this option that only works
in this segment
experts say the widespread use of
vaccines probably won't happen before
spring of next year
as trials determine whether they will
work will last
and will be safe we really have to be
prepared because if things go
really well this could be honest within
months and boy do we want to see an end
to this
vaccine distribution will be a huge
challenge worldwide
but it's an exciting prospect bringing
the pandemic under control
reopening the economy once and for all
and getting life
back to normal eric sorensen global news
toronto
we are far from normal now and as
frustrating as it is the only way to
reduce the spread of covet 19 now is to
reduce the number of people we come into
contact with
that message was repeated by politicians
and public health experts again today
because numbers in canada keep rising in
multiple places
more than 2500 new cases were reported
across the country today
in manitoba premier brian pallister says
people who have been ignoring the rules
and spreading the virus
need to get with the program when you
have symptoms
don't go to church when you have
symptoms
don't go out to the bar when
when you're waiting for a test result
back for heaven's sakes
don't have a house party grow up
and stop going out there and given
people covet
in saskatchewan today 54 new cases were
reported alberta continues to see a
spike more than 500
new cases reported there today and there
are more than 200 in b.c
two more positive cases in yukon cases
are creeping up in the atlantic bubble
five new ones reported there in quebec
there were more than 800 new cases today
restrictions in red zones have been
extended to the end of november
and ontario had more than 850 new cases
today
tight restrictions are in place in
several regions in ontario including
toronto
and officials have warned that could be
expanded to the hulton and durham
regions but no decision has been made
yet
premier doug ford says he is trying to
strike a balance between saving lives
and keeping businesses afloat we have to
protect people
and we have to protect their livelihoods
and the best way we can protect our
economy is protecting people
and keeping this virus contained
political leaders across the country
and around the world are struggling with
that balance how to keep infection rates
down and the economy
open as mike delay reports it has led to
lots of frustration
was it covet 19 fatigue or frayed nerves
a 22 year old was shot and killed in
toronto on sunday
after an argument in a liquor store over
physical distancing
regionally political leaders say they're
tired of having to adapt to covet 19 as
well
the mayors of regions just outside
toronto sent premier doug ford's
strongly worded letters
in essence don't shut us down again we
want to have just a little more autonomy
as our individual regions dictate so
you can't take a cookie-cutter approach
to to this particular situation
at his daily press conference he made it
clear he hears it all
there's always been pushback on on all
sides but that doesn't make it easier to
come up with a plan
ford has been reluctant to declare
another lockdown preferring instead to
go with targeted shutdowns
which haven't been popular with the
businesses affected we have to have a
happy balance
and it's not easy to make sure that
on one hand we keep businesses going and
and i just i just want to give people
hope
and perhaps shockingly the hope is in
the current numbers
while there's no denying the steep climb
in cases in september
epidemiologists look at the seven-day
averages for a clearer picture of the
province's health
and october's data does show what could
be the start of a plateau
if you bring in nothing you get in
serious trouble and that's what we've
seen in the number of american states
and what's happening in europe right now
but ontario's measures are kind of
middle of the road
and we've seen middle of the road
measures be able to decrease things
elsewhere so i'm cautiously optimistic
but that doesn't ease the stress on
businesses desperate to reopen or kids
in the hot zones
where halloween has been canceled
microlight global news toronto
new restrictions are coming to canada's
western provinces after a spike in cases
over the weekend
b.c is now limiting household gatherings
to immediate family members and six
close contacts
and alberta is putting in new
restrictions in edmonton
and calgary we have now crossed a
tipping point
and are losing the balance we have been
seeking
there is now a mandatory 15-person limit
on all social gatherings in edmonton and
calgary including dinner parties
receptions
and other social events the change will
not impact structured events like dining
out
worship and wedding and funeral services
hundreds of health care workers and
support staff walked off the job at
several hospitals in edmonton
and calgary and other municipalities
today they're angry about the province's
plan
to cut 11 000 jobs mostly by outsourcing
the work to private companies and
accused the province of being reckless
and provocative during the pandemic
the province was already struggling to
keep up with scheduled surgeries and
increased hospitalizations because of
covid19
alberta health services calls today's
walkout illegal it says it affects all
of its facilities
and says it puts patients at risk
non-urgent ambulatory care procedures
and clinic visits were postponed
in ottawa opposition parties voted in
favor of a conservative motion to
investigate the government's handling of
the pandemic
they want answers on how much money has
been spent and on what
it's not a confidence vote so there's no
risk it will bring down the government
but as michael couture reports it will
keep up the pressure
on the prime minister i am seriously
saying
that our contracts vaccine ppe and rapid
test kits
are in jeopardy that warning from the
procurement minister came just hours
before a vote for proposed parliamentary
probe
of pandemic spending anita anand says
disclosing details of the deals the
government has brokered with certain
companies
will put a chill on future negotiations
and put canadians at risk
our relationships with suppliers will
not only be negatively impacted
they may also disappear last week the
president of canadian manufacturers and
exporters
wrote a letter to the minister
expressing concern over confidential
business information
being disclosed in the public in a
statement to global news vaccine maker
pfizer
said it worries the release of
commercially sensitive information
could be damaging it's just asking some
basic questions
the conservative health critic says her
motion is about government
accountability of pandemic spending
not revealing commercial sensitivities
which
would be reviewed first by the
parliamentary law clerk
it basically means that there's a
special person whose job it is
to make sure that this type of sensitive
information is not released
unduly but what about that claim that
businesses would walk away from
negotiations with canada
if certain information was published
this expert on government business
relations
says you have to balance transparency
and privacy concerns
know the privilege information that we
might have shared with government in
order to get
that procurement contract going how do
we know that it's not going to get
in the hands of the public well
transparency will be just as important
when the government presents a budget
update this fall
but in a virtual discussion with the
canadian chamber of commerce
prime minister justin trudeau said that
update will not contain a fiscal anchor
donna okay michael couture in ottawa
thanks
voters in saskatchewan are choosing who
will steer that province through the
rest of the pandemic
this is premier scott moe's first
election since taking over the
leadership of the saskatchewan party
from brad wall
moe is hoping for a fourth consecutive
term for the party a record number of
votes were cast
during advance polls in saskatchewan and
the first federal by-elections to take
place in the pandemic are happening
today in two toronto ridings
voters will choose who they want to
replace former finance minister bill
morneau
and liberal mp michael levitt who
resigned the writings of toronto center
in york center both longtime liberal
strongholds
well-known broadcaster marcy ian is
running for the liberals in toronto
center
the new leader of the federal green
party anamy paul is running there too
in york center community activist yara
sax is hoping to retain the seat for the
liberals
maxine bernier is also running there the
leader of the people's party lost his
seat in quebec
in the last federal election and in the
u.s there is one week left for president
donald trump and his rival joe biden to
win over voters
more than 60 million americans have
already made up their minds and cast
ballots either by mail or by voting in
person
that is unprecedented and so is the
pandemic of course covet 19 case numbers
are rising in 44 states
the rolling average of daily new cases
is higher than it's ever been nearly
seventy thousand
more than forty thousand americans were
hospitalized with kovid 19 yesterday
that's the fifth day in a row
the number has been that high and more
than 225 000 americans are known to have
died from covet 19.
yet as jackson proskow reports president
trump's campaign strategy seems to be
the pandemic is no big deal with
every icu in el paso texas now full
health officials have activated field
hospitals and issued fresh stay at home
orders and a nightly curfew
the reasons for the new order have to do
with the
that we're at a crisis stage cases are
on the rise in almost every single state
on the campaign trail president donald
trump is trying to sell a different
reality
as he gathers thousands of supporters at
tightly packed rallies
we're rounding the turn you know all
they want to talk about is covert by the
way on november 4th you won't be hearing
so much
about it monday trump tweeted case is up
because we test test test
a fake news media conspiracy we
not only lack a national strategy we
actually have a commander-in-chief
and his entire administration who are
actively
trying to work against some of the most
clear
kind of ways to contain this virus there
is more defiance at the white house
where
five aides to vice president mike pence
have tested positive
we're not going to control the pandemic
we are going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations what are we going to get
because it is a contagious virus just
like the flu
the way he's handling covet is just
absolutely
totally irresponsible for joe biden the
pandemic and the loss of at least 225
000 american lives form a closing
argument about the need for a change in
leadership
he's gone around the bend i mean we are
in real
trouble that's still a tough sell for a
large number of americans
while 82 percent of biden supporters see
the coronavirus as a very important
issue in the election
just 24 percent of trump supporters feel
the same way
with no strategy there seems to be no
changing the trajectory of the pandemic
at current rates of infection the u.s is
on track to record nearly half a million
new cases
between now and election day donna
jackson prosco in washington thank you a
new itinerary for swoop
coming up how the discount carrier is
hoping for a rebound in passengers
the finnish airline thin air is trying
to find a unique way to adapt
it is selling business class meals at
the supermarket
the food which includes teriyaki beef
and smoked arctic char has become an
instant hit sixteen hundred meals were
sold
within days of hitting store shelves not
an airplane in sight
abbotsford isn't exactly the
cosmopolitan capital of british columbia
but now a low-cost carrier is counting
on canadians traveling between toronto
and vancouver
to use that suburban city as a landing
pad as robin gill reports the airline is
hoping the new route will have canadians
swooping up deals
and travel within canada swoop airlines
first flight between toronto and
abbotsford bc
may not be jam-packed but at 99
each way the ultra low-cost carrier is
hoping to lure canadians eager to
vacation
at home we're positioning even this new
route we're starting today
is about the recovery we're positioning
swoop for for the rebound that we know
will come but but frankly isn't here yet
border restrictions are in place so
that's stopping ontarians from crossing
into buffalo new york to use cheap
carriers like
jetblue and british columbians aren't
heading to bellingham washington to take
advantage of allegiant air's low-cost
flights
so smaller airports in canada like
abbotsford
could potentially capitalize last year
42 million dollars left the country on
travel spend
and this year if we can get some of that
travel spend back even just a small part
of it
that will be a huge difference to the
canadian economy destination canada a
federal agency that monitors tourism in
this country
has been looking at travel habits on the
internet
the research shows we are searching for
places to go
domestically with an eye on bc and
ontario
because those provinces don't have a
14-day quarantine
when traveling interprovincially maybe
it's a bit of a roll of the dice to see
if that actually does play out
this tourism marketing expert says no
quarantines and low fares
are just pieces of the puzzle to
increase demand just because someone
went on the internet
and planned a dream vacation or thought
it would be nice to go to toronto
i don't know that we can be certain that
that's going to happen
still the price was right for these
passengers price i just paid was the
lowest price i've paid in probably the
last 20 years coming to british columbia
i got around trips and it was about
four hundred dollars or two for swoop
it's counting on travel to take off
again
after it cut capacity by 95 percent at
the beginning of the pandemic
and knows it isn't the only airline in
turbulent times
robin gill global news abbotsford bc
still ahead a nation celebrates why
chile's constitution is back in the
hands
of the people
look at this show of defiance in belarus
after 11 weeks of constant protest today
there was a nationwide strike
supporters of the opposition are keeping
up the pressure on alexander lukashenka
to step down as president protesters
threatened to paralyze the country if he
did not relinquish power by
midnight a deadline he ignored people
have been taking to the streets since he
claimed victory in an august poll widely
viewed as rigged
human rights groups say more than 150
people were arrested
today in chile they are celebrating
people there voted overwhelmingly to
tear up the old constitution
and write a new one
78 percent of people supported scrapping
chile's old constitution imposed four
decades ago by
military general augusto pinochet the
referendum was called after the
government hiked rail fairs last year
sparking protests
that flared into a movement against the
country's high cost of living
we've got to do everything we can to
make sure this guy gets elected
up next why his devoted followers are
still backing president trump
as november 3rd approaches the u.s is so
polarized it's sometimes not easy to
even have a civilized conversation with
voters
about who they think should be the next
president of the united states
president trump likes to say no one has
more devoted supporters than he does
our mike armstrong went to a trump rally
in pennsylvania
to ask supporters why their man deserves
four more years
they are nothing if not passionate
donald trump coming to lancaster pulled
thousands out to the airport it's not
the nicest day but you wanted to be here
how come
support president trump make sure he
gets reelected
my honest desire to see my president
i i can't wait to be right here in our
own hometown
see air force one fly in i mean it's
just a spectacle
2020 baby it felt a little like a rock
concert complete with vendors hawking
t-shirts and hats
trump chain baby trump train and a crowd
ready to hear the greatest hits i'm
happy to be here it's my second rally
and um
pray to god he wins now it may have been
a tumultuous four years with donald
trump in the white house no one in this
crowd seemed to dispute that
but they will argue that trump fulfilled
his maga promise
that he did what he could to make
america great again
in a lot of ways yes i mean i'm a
business owner my business was doing
much better before this
whole covet started then than before
pennsylvania's governor has been very
critical of the trump campaign
holding events in this state and
disregarding public health guidance
he's called it dangerous and
manipulative there were masks at this
rally but there was
very little physical distancing there
also seemed to be very little fear
of covet 19. you can't shut down the
state you can't shut down the country
you got to keep america open you got to
keep businesses open you know
you're killing people more so by
shutting down
the one thing about trump's support is
that it's being rock solid he may not
have expanded his base or even tried
much but the people in his camp
aren't interested in leaving trump we
were told over and over
was put in power by someone god
by god yeah he's not finished yet
four more years that passion is one
thing
trump has going for him his supporters
are eager to vote there is a confidence
in this crowd that
even behind in the polls trump can still
pull this out
pollsters they say didn't predict he'd
win four years ago
either mike armstrong global news
lancaster pennsylvania
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the moon
nasa has confirmed signs of water have
been found on the moon it's not a pool
of water but molecular water and it was
discovered on the sunlit surface
which opens the possibility larger
deposits may exist all over the lunar
surface not just
in the cold shadowed places which may
not have seen a single ray of sunlight
for potentially
billions of years thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you